Okay, it's finally time to do a little data wrangling
for ourselves. We're going to look at parsing CSV files in Python.
In this case, we're going to be reading the CSV data into
our program and creating on dictionary for each item in that
file. So you might ask yourself, why would we do something
like this? Why not just open it in a spreadsheet application?
One reason, is because if the file is big, let's tens
or even hundreds of megabytes, opening it in a spreadsheet application
like Excel can be slow, inefficient or maybe even
impossible. Your app might do the software equivalent of
this. Another reason we might want to programmatically process
tabular data, is because we might have a whole
lot of files to process. So, doing it manually
in the spreadsheet application simply isn't an option. Alright,
let's take a look at the code provided. Here
you can see, we have a parse file application.
In this exercise, we're going to be working with
the Beatles' disckography data, one more time. You'll be
working in the parse file function in the provided
code. And, your assignment is to use the Python
function split to parse each row into a dictionary.
For each dictionary, the names of the fields will
serve as the keys and the value you find on a given row will serve as the values
for those keys. You should produce an array of
these dictionaries, one dictionary for each item remember. And you
should return that array from the parse file function.
Now, one final instruction here, is that rather than processing
the entire file, you should only parse the first
ten lines in this file. If you go beyond that,
you run into trouble with this particular dataset. Since this
is the first exercise we're looking at in this course.
Let me talk a little bit about this test
function here. We're providing this as a means for you
to test your implementation of parse file. This will run
a little bit of code which calls the parse file
function and sample the result that it gets back
from parse file, checking to see if it has the
expected values. When you actually submit your program, we'll be
running some different test code, possibly on a different dataset.